enrico j'aimerais qu'on fasse un petit
jeu avec les chroniques on va faire ses
lamelles le nv casque va te mettre un
casque de travail tu vas devoir chanter
les chansons que tu entends ils vont
devoir trouver de quoi laisser la satin
deschamps ça très très actuel est ce
qu'on peut avoir le casque s'il vous
plaît ou bien il est il s'est trop
longue l'inspecteur merci josep ils se
déplacent aussi vite que doc gynéco
alors attention c'est bon tu t'occupes
du casque elle rit côte est ce que tu
entends je t'entends alors là c'est bon
vas-y alors attention on va mettre le
premier titre c'est parti est ce que tu
peux chanter ce que tu entends enrico il
entend pas là mon esprit je ne vois à
s'enferrer alors maître gims non alors
il refait leur effet le rhdp le refais
le refais le champion dans ses sorties
ce que tu crois à ce que je ne sais pas
où je suis mais je suis je ne comprends
plus rien dire
[Applaudissements]
siala 3 attention à la croix vas-y
saladerie qu est ce que tu peux nous
chanter ça lasse elle côtoie dans mon
coeur bat pour toi si tu m'écoutes et
ivana à nana na na na
non je chante ça c'est quoi un geek au c
sait-on jamais
[Musique]
mettez moi mettez moi
là c'est plus c'est plus facile
mettez-moi l'a4 l'a86 dans tous les bons
coups alors dans cette dernière a été
une petite dernière qui dit attention
vous jouez chez google voire pedrico
quand tu veux mais tu échec vous les
mettez là cinq la tête et du zouk
il va nous chanter ce qu'ils entendent
en un instant et au soleil
[Rires]
bien soleil j'ai bronzé sous le soleil
mais berne aux frontons non alors on va
écouter je sais pas depuis ma mort
à
hahaha
c'est magnifique c'est magnifique à
toiture à chanter c'est dur tu la salle
anne rigaud même parce que c'est moi
même peut-être que c'est une des siennes
de chanter non non non non et bien ce
jeu de quoi allier nakamura
non non je crois pas non non non non
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
l'as monaco a dit on fait la new talent
a retenu contre champions n'a pas trouvé
que je suis la chanter
citoyen américaine dit non non non non
1 ça donne envie d'écrire des nouvelles
chansons nanana c'était à temps je suis
même pas sur moi même je crois que ça
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
on